前髪ー
もうすぐ髪色もちゃんと変えるんで
もう少しの辛抱です
この謎の髪型にもうしばらくお付き合いください
（キラリン）
もう何しても格好もつかないよ
はい、というわけで今日はですね、
お料理というか、まぁーそれっぽい感じですね
ちょっとね、リクエスト的なものをいただきまして
あれ、、、スマホあったあった
リクエスト的なのをいただきまして、、
やりましょう！！
というわけで今日は実際に３つのものを準備しました
はい、まずはシンプルにコーラと
これはマーガリンですね
あとそこら辺の卵
この３つを混ぜるとバニラ味になるということを聞いたので
今回は実際にやってみようと思います
ちょっとのどの調子が悪くて
この３つを混ぜると、、
うーん、のどが、、、
イヤッホーイ
卵だね
とりあえず卵だな
よしっ
これ黄身とか白身とかって関係あんのかな
どうでもいっか
特に問題はないと思います！！
卵、まずっ
卵の殻ってなんか、、しょっぱいわ
とりあえずコーラっしょ
うわー、、えーこれうわー、、えーー
大丈夫なの、これ
えっ、俺これ知らないよ
もう、ちょっと得体のしれない感じになってます
泡の立ち方がもうグロい
こっからマーガリンを入れます
この入れ方は絶対だめだ
決まったね、そういう調理器具がないんで
難しいんすよね
こんなもんかな
オッケー
あとは
て、これ大丈夫
なんか、弾力のある泡になってんだけど
なんか泡がねもう、こうこうなんか、、
あっ、そうでもねーや
やべっ、ちょっと切らなきゃ
マーガリン切らなきゃ
いいぞ
こんなもんっしょ
よし、、完成です
卵　✖　コーラ　✖　、、、
マーガリン！！
もうぱっと見ね、なんかちょっとしたねデザートに見えるよね
いやー、味だよ大事なのは味
本当にバニラの味になっているのか
そこがね非常に見どころなんですよ
じゃーさっそくちょっくら飲んでみよーと思います
これがねーおいしかったら別にいいんすよ
でもまずかったらもう大変すよ
そこら辺をちゃんとねおさえて
さっそく飲んでいこうと思います
いや、ほんとにね味ですべてが決まっちゃうからね
いただきます！！
破天荒な味だな
いやー、、きついこれは！！
バニラ風味はするんすよ、バニラ感はあるんすけど
なん、、なんでだろう、、マーガリン入れすぎたのかな、、、
なんかうまく飲めない
卵のヌルヌル感が
絶妙にマッチしてますね
たまんない逸品だ
悪い意味で
なんかすべてが絶妙に絡み合って
ちょっとまってこれ、バニラじゃない
えっまって、ネタじゃないほうでやばいんだけど
ダメダメちょっと、、、
フィニッシュ　フィニッシュ！！！
はい、というわけでいかがだったでしょうか
今回のメニューは、卵　✖　コーラ　✖、、、
バター
この絶妙なハーモニーでできるバニラ味の飲み物
これはまさに、はじめ‘S　ポイント、、、、
最高に、、まずい！！